en 1953 de premières études médicales
démontrent que la cigarette provoque le
cancer du poumon pourtant à coups de
milliards de dollars des années durant
les cigarettis vont s'employer à masquer
la vérité et s'assurer de l'addiction
des fumeurs grâce à la nicotine c'est ce
que vient de nous révéler c'est enquête
tirée de la série les mensonges de
l'histoire et réalisé par Bénédicte
delfo quand s'arrêtera cette sinique
entreprise menée par l'industrie du
tabac au prix de combien de vies ce sont
les questions dont nous allons débattre
maintenant avec nos invités présents
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau de débat doc
en commençant par vous Claude et vin
bienvenue vous avez été ministre de la
Santé entre 1988 et
1991 c'était bien sûr dans le
gouvernement de Michel Rocard puis
directeur de l'agence régionale de santé
d'Île-de-France et vous êtes aujourd'hui
avocat au barreau de Paris Anne Laurence
Le Faou est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes médecin responsable
du centre le tabacologie de l'Hôpital
Européen Georges Pompidou bien sûr situé
à Paris et présidente de la Société
Francophone de tabacologie puis enfin
avec nous Marc lomazi bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste ancien rédacteur en
chef adjoint du Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France et auteur de ce livre comment la
mafia du tabac nous manipule publié chez
Flammarion alors là c'est évidemment en
lien très direct avec le film que nous
venons de voir Clos des vins c'est vrai
que ce film peu inquiéter parce que je
voudrais que on recontextualise ce qui a
été votre action à la tête du ministère
de la Santé donc entre 88 et 91 que
saviez-vous exactement de ce qui est
révélé dans ce documentaire et pourquoi
avez-vous décidé de légiférer contre le
tabac pas seulement le tabac d'ailleurs
également l'alcool parce que là on se
dit vous deviez faire face à des forts
vont souffler par ce formidable hobbying
qu'on découvre dans ce documentaire qui
est l'obéenne des cigarettes
alors ce qu'on savait en 1988 au moment
où effectivement j'ai commencé à assurer
la responsabilité du Ministère de la
Santé c'était d'abord le nombre de décès
liés et le nombre de pathologies
cancer maladie cardiovasculaires
maladies respiratoire liée à la
consommation de tabac donc vous saviez
qu'à peu près 70 000 personnes par an en
France mouraient du tabac pourrait
effectivement de cette de cette
consommation donc le lien dont on voit
d'ailleurs dans le film qu'elle est
apparue que ce lien est apparu
progressivement suite d'un certain
nombre d'études scientifiques ce lien on
le connaissait très bien et donc moi
ministre de la Santé à ce moment-là ma
préoccupation assez rapidement a été
effectivement de je dirais de protéger
alors c'est peut-être un peu on peut si
je puisse dire de dire ça maintenant
mais ne protéger la santé des
concitoyens je veux dire c'est le rôle
du ministre de la Santé c'était après la
campagne électorale présidentielle qui
avait vu des professeurs de santé
publique
qui était concerné à la fois dans le
traitement des cancers sur un certain
nombre de sujets de santé publique
interpeller les deux candidats à
l'élection présidentielle qui était
d'une part François Mitterrand qui
abordait son deuxième mandat d'autre
part Jacques Chirac qui avait été
interpellé pendant la campagne
présidentielle pour dire voilà les
effets du tabac et de l'alcool et voilà
les mesures qu'il faudrait prendre et
les mesures bah c'est essentiellement
travailler sur la publicité donc
concernant le tabac on y reviendra
peut-être car c'est aussi intéressant de
voir comment pour pouvoir effectivement
passer des messages il y a à l'heure sur
la publicité sur les messages
naturellement parce qu'on présente le
produit de manière attrayante pour aller
pour pousser à la consommation pour
aller chercher de nouveaux consommateurs
on voit les femmes on voit les jeunes et
ça continue d'ailleurs aujourd'hui sur
des manières beaucoup plus insidieuses
puisque effectivement la loi a interdit
la publicité directe et indirecte
d'autre part ce qui est beaucoup plus
perçu par la population naturellement
c'est la réglement de la fumée de
l'usage du tabac dans les lieux à usage
collectifs avec l'interdiction de fumer
dans les lieux à usage collectif puis
d'autre part il y avait un volet sur la
sortie des produits de l'indice des prix
permettant d'augmenter les prix des
produits en question qui est aussi un
des facteurs de réduction de la
consommation alors on y reviendra
notamment avec Marc lemaziz ça rapporte
beaucoup d'argent à l'état cette affaire
ça rapporte aujourd'hui mais on y
reviendra environ 15 milliards d'euros
par an au budget de l'État j'imagine que
votre collègue des finances mais les
effets collègues des finances par
exemple assez mauvais œil une loi du
type que vous avez réussi à faire voter
il y a tout de même là des des enjeux
très antagonistes qui se jouaient
j'imagine au sein même de votre
gouvernement alors on y reviendra sans
doute ça rapporte certes mais les
pathologies le traitement des
pathologies liées à la consommation du
tabac comme à la consommation d'alcool
d'ailleurs coûte beaucoup plus cher que
ça me rapporte mais on y reviendra
manière mais dans le contexte de
l'époque ce qu'il faut effectivement
avoir en mémoire alors ce que peut-être
on a oublié c'est qu'il y avait en plus
à l'époque une société française qui
était effectivement une société de
production de tabac la SEITA la société
des tabacs qui étaient à un
établissement public c'est-à-dire qui
fabriquait effectivement le les
cigarettes en France et donc il y avait
une activité d'ailleurs certaines
manufactures de tabac était le premier
employeur d'un certain nombre de bassins
dans un certain nombre de villes
effectivement l'activité liée au tabac
lorsque en effet progressivement les
usines ont été amenées à fermer compte
tenu des mesures de santé publique qui
ont été et puis délocalisation aussi
a disparu en tant que tel même s'il y a
eu des reprises par ailleurs mais
effectivement ça posait un certain
nombre de problèmes économiques qui sont
à prendre en considération d'ailleurs et
à l'époque dont vous parlez il y avait
une vingtaine de manufactures en France
il y en a plus du tout vous l'avez dit
et c'est employé entre c'est 13000
personnes pas oublier les buralistes qui
comptent dans ce circuit on en reparlera
peut-être avec vous il y a aujourd'hui
23000 buralistes en France oui c'est
vrai que les maladies du tabac
maintenant on sait à quel coûtent
finalement à l'Assurance Maladie 26
milliards d'euros par an donc
effectivement c'est pas le même budget
parce que l'État a son budget et la
sécurité sociale le sien donc finalement
il y a un jeu un peu donc subtil parce
que c'est pas vraiment le même pot mais
globalement ça ça contribue beaucoup au
déficit aux difficultés la tabacologue
que vous êtes n'est pas dupe de tout ce
qu'on a vu et n'est pas dupe du cynisme
qu'entreprend jusqu'à nos jours cette
industrie du tabac auprès des jeunes
vient de dire que le des vins vient de
le rappeler auprès des personnes les
plus défavorisées ce sont eux qui fument
le plus dans notre pays on a pas dû de
tout ça non puis ça vraiment la même
entre 2019
fume régulièrement une femme sur cinq
les femmes fument un tout petit peu
moins et puis vous l'avez vu dans les
dans les milieux défavorisés c'est 30%
des personnes
issues de milieu défavorités qui sont
des fumeurs à quel âge est-ce qu'on fume
sa première cigarette aujourd'hui chez
les jeunes parce que c'est une des six
privilégiés par cette industrie oui tout
à fait donc
l'expérimentation baisse donc il y a
moins de jeunes qui expérimentent qui
testent le tabac mais ça reste quand
même 15 ans à peu près donc le alors
c'est plus âgé qu'auparavant mais
maintenant les jeunes deviennent plus
facilement fumeurs quotidien ce dont on
s'aperçoit c'est que
bon les données les plus récentes de
période de confinement il semble quand
même que ça marque le pas c'est à dire
que on est moins d'expérimentateur moins
de fumeurs quotidiens chez les jeunes
mais tout de même des difficultés parce
qu'il y a pas mal de fumeurs de
pas mal de jeunes qui n'utilisent que la
cigarette électronique sans fumer alors
ça sont les substituer la cigarette pour
pouvoir parler tout à l'heure Marc
lemazier est-ce qu'on peut dire que
l'industrie du tabac cette mafia du
tabac c'est comme ça que vous l'appelez
de votre livre a perdu la partie
aujourd'hui et là en grande partie
perdue la partie mais il faut quand même
se souvenir que la partie a été
extrêmement dure extrêmement violente
si on revient sur le le documentaire à
un moment donné quelqu'un dit il faut
bien se rendre compte que les big tobacs
les géants distributs tabac ce sont en
fait comme les trafiquants de drogue
c'est la même chose ils savent que c'est
un produit qui tue et malgré tout ils
vont tout faire pour continuer à le
vendre et donc
à un moment donné il y avait encore un
doute
léger mais encore un doute qu'on pouvait
instiller dans l'esprit des décideurs et
des membres du Congrès sur est-ce que
tout ça est vraiment lié est-ce que
c'est aussi simple que ça à partir du
moment où le doute a été levé on aurait
pu se dire c'est ce qui est bien
expliqué dans le documentaire on aurait
pu se dire bon bah ils ont compris que
ça tue ils vont arrêter et ben non ils
arrêtent pas ils font une espèce de
complot où ils se mettent tous d'accord
entre eux alors qu'ils sont concurrents
ils se mettent tous d'accord entre eux
ils créent des instituts bidons et puis
il duplique cette stratégie à l'échelle
mondiale et moi la question que je me
suis posée quand j'ai écrit ce livre en
2015 quand j'ai découvert en fait
l'histoire de Jeffrey végan c'est est-ce
que ça existe toujours
est-ce que l'industrie du tabac c'est
toujours ça et je me suis rendu compte
qu'en fait c'est véritablement une mafia
je donne un exemple
en
2003 de mémoire il y a le plan concert
de Jacques Chirac le plan cancer de
Jacques Chirac c'est une énorme
opération qui est le premier plan qu'on
sait hein
et Jacques Chirac est très sensibilisé à
ce problème de de la santé et il décide
d'un plan cancer extrêmement dur ils
vont tout faire pour essayer de le faire
capoter appartement ou au sommet de
l'État on décide d'y aller on y va plus
40% d'augmentation des prix du tabac le
marché s'écroule
des gros fumeurs de cigares
que recevant justement les professeurs
de santé publique volontairement il est
il avait allumé à cigare en les recevant
enfin bon voilà donc mais indépendamment
de ça dans le débat parlementaire
effectivement mais il y a eu des
oppositions du ministre des Finances du
ministre des budgets et Michel Rocard à
arbitré assez fortement d'ailleurs y
compris ça aussi qui est intéressant y
compris en prenant appui justement sur
la position qu'avait exprimé et qui
avait lancé dans le débat public les
cinq professeurs de santé publique que
j'ai cité tout à l'heure c'est
intéressant parce que moi je me suis
beaucoup appuyé sur ce débat social si
je puis dire ce débat de société et sur
ce débat médical d'une certaine manière
et c'est ça qui a permis au moment des
arbitrages de pouvoir gagner les
arbitrages sur le projet de loi ceci
étant ça a continué pendant un petit
moment il y a eu après alors ça reste
dans les anecdotes mais ça il y a eu
après une publicité pour un vêtement qui
s'appelait Chevignon
des commandes des blousons qui étaient
très prisés par les jeunes il y avait
une marque de cigarettes qui avait
utilisé le thème de ce titre pour lancer
une cigarette avec la bénédiction du
ministre du Budget et la montée de la
polémique publique a conduit le ministre
du Budget a demandé effectivement parce
que c'était la SEITA qui était à
l'origine a demandé à la cita de retirer
ce produit donc c'est vrai que y compris
au sein du du gouvernement il y a eu des
tensions bon ceci étant sur la loi
elle-même on l'a emporté bien que le
décret d'application en dehors puisque
la loi date de janvier 91 le décret
d'application prix en 92 par Bernard
couchter malheureusement sur
l'interdiction de fumer dans les lieux à
usage collectif et malheureusement
inapplicable et il ne vient ça ne
deviendra applicable qu'en 2006 donc
c'est un combat permanent et puis votre
loi arrivera 15 ans à prendre ce qui a
été la première loi c'était Simone Veil
ce qui est la première 76
ans après arrive votre
quand on parle de mafia c'est vraiment
ça c'est à dire que à partir du moment
où on interdit la publicité qu'est-ce
que fait n'importe quel entreprise
normale entre guillemets c'est qu'elle
applique la loi les cigarettes non les
cigaritiers ce qu'ils vont faire s'ils
vont détourner la loi alors je vous
donne un exemple
on sponsorise une course automobile et
sur les ailerons on a les couleurs très
significatives d'un des paquets de
cigarettes les plus connus et le plus
vendus en France rouge et blanc avec des
chevrons rouges et blanc or il se trouve
que sur les voitures de course si vous
peignez en rouge et en blanc les
ailerons ça fait des chevrons donc tout
le monde sait de quoi on parle tout le
monde sait et on voyait quand la voiture
passait la ligne d'arrivée on voyait
chevrons c'est un exemple la ligne de
vêtements c'est un exemple le pari Dakar
le pari Dakar il y avait des camions
marque des cigaritiers qui étaient
placées devant l'arrivée du Dakar et
quand les coureurs arrivaient on ne
voyait que ça je vais juste rajouter
finalement à l'heure actuelle c'est
quand même la même stratégie dire que
avec
bon à une caution scientifique ça
s'appelle la Fondation
donc pour un monde sans fumée donc qui
est financé par Philippe Morris
International il y a vraiment des
experts notamment un expert qui
s'appelle derekia qui a été donc
débauché de l'OMS qui comme une
institution donc défendant la santé
publique pour diriger cette fondation et
avec des études sur les nouveaux
produits du tabac de façon à ce que
l'industrie finalement se réoriente vers
de nouvelles activités et avec les mêmes
méthodes de marketing et avec la même
possibilité d'infiltrer différents
publics et en fait ça n'a pas changé
c'est tout à fait la même chose avec une
force
les produits un peu variés sur les
substituts avant de parler des
substituts je voudrais qu'on en vienne
tout de même à l'aspect budgétaire 15
milliards d'euros c'est en moyenne ce
que rapporte le tabac chaque année et
j'ai regardé combien avait été attribué
au plan concert qui est en cours c'est
1,73
milliards d'euros pour 5 ans donc
l'industrie du tabac rapporte
70 milliards sur 5 ans et sur cette même
période qui est attribuée à la lutte
contre le cancer c'est 1,7 milliards cet
écart est considérable à quoi sert
l'argent qu'on récupère dans les caisses
de l'État grâce au tabac à la lutte
contre le tabac le tabagisme à la lutte
contre le cancer visiblement c'est pas
le cas si on regarde ces chiffres là on
a du mal à comprendre quand même Claude
docteur évoquait tout à l'heure c'est
que quand même globalement le coût du
cancer
en fait il faut intégrer le traitement
c'est-à-dire le coût à la société c'est
quand même 23 milliards donc
ce qu'on identifie comme Plan Cancer
ceci étant c'est vrai que il y a pas la
totalité de de ce qui est prélevé en
taxe sur le tabac qui est alloué à la
lutte contre le cancer puisque
effectivement comme il était indiqué
tout à l'heure en effet il y a une part
qui est qui reste dans le budget de
l'État et par ailleurs le traitement des
pathologies est assuré par la Sécurité
Sociale ceci étant globalement c'est
quand même des finances publiques comme
maman c'est des prélèvements
obligatoires à c'est-à-dire que là c'est
des prélèvements obligatoires sur les
entreprises il y a par ailleurs
effectivement d'autres prélèvements qui
servent aussi à payer à financer la
sécurité sociale donc qu'il y ait pas
suffisamment de de de financement pour
la prévention moi je serais absolument
d'accord à condition naturellement qu'on
puisse aussi cibler je dirais les les
axes de prévention et je pense
effectivement c'est quand même un des
une des préoccupations qu'on doit avoir
c'est développer la prévention
développer la prévention passer les
messages en direction des jeunes en
direction des consommateurs en direction
des catégories sociales qui sont les
plus grandes consommatrices et qui sont
les plus défavorisées et effectivement
il faut développer cette prévention ils
mettent les crédits mais globalement on
peut pas dire si vous voulez que l'État
fait du bénéfice globalement en laissant
se développer l'industrie du tabac parce
que les effets sur la finance publique
sont beaucoup plus lourds si je puis
dire financièrement que ça ne rapporte à
l'état bon moi je voudrais avoir votre
avis sur cette question plus de 70
milliards d'euros
rapportés par le tabac à l'état et
seulement 1,7 et quelques milliards
destinés au prochain plan cancer
la première cause enfin s'il y a quand
même les maladies cardiovasculaires
d'abord on a dit pulmonaire et le cancer
donc c'est un vraiment énorme
pathologies et en fait c'est les 15
milliards c'est tous les ans qui tombent
tandis qu'il faut parfois d'années
d'exposition pour que survienne les
maladies donc finalement c'est un débat
assez compliqué parce qu'on reçoit de
l'argent tout de suite on préfère
toujours avoir de l'argent tout de suite
plutôt que d'imaginer qu'un jour on
devra payer donc des dépenses de santé
mais c'est vraiment très faible ce qui
est très attribué à la prévention la
prévention primaire donc le fait
d'empêcher que des jeunes fument avec
des programmes particulièrement
destinées aux jeunes d'estime de même et
aussi tout l'argent qui aide les fumeur
à s'arrêter parce que là c'est souvent
c'est quand même plusieurs tentatives
qui sont nécessaires avec éventuellement
de l'aide chez les fumeurs qui ont le
plus de difficultés donc spécialisés et
des traitements pharmacologiques et ou
d'autres possibilités mais c'est très
très important de financer et de mettre
en tout ce qu'on peut comme argent dans
la prévention primaire et secondaire
c'est à dire dès qu'on fume et les
personnes et parce que ce qu'on voit
vraiment ce qui est choquant à mon avis
dans l'industrie c'est que elle a
racheté quand même 75% du tabac la
racheté 75% d'une entreprise s'appelle
Vectra qui fabrique des inhalateurs
bronchiques c'est-à-dire à la fois vous
vous pensez que c'est la fin du tabac on
vous dit bah vraiment nous on veut tout
de fumer
mais quand même c'est pas une échéance
brève et vous achetez
donc vous rendez les gens malades du
tabac avec des maladies diverses
pulmonaires et ensuite vous rachetez une
entreprise le poison et après vous
racheter
les médicaments c'est quand même quelque
chose de particulièrement donc cynique
effectivement que l'on voit bien dans le
dans votre documentaire si on prend le
vraiment l'exemple de la France c'est
que vous avez eu un moment donné en
France concernant le la mortalité
routière je me rappelle
d'un clip où on voyait des gens allongés
par terre et on me disait ça fait 17000
morts par an c'est l'équivalent de la
ville de Mazamet rayé chaque année de la
carte et il y a une politique contre le
l'alcoolisme volant qui a été mise en
place très bien accepté par la
population qui a compris comme la
ceinture de sécurité il y a pas eu de il
y avait un enjeu très fort de de santé
publique il y a pas eu de résistance la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est
puisque on savait que ça tuait comment
se fait-il que ça met aussi longtemps et
là ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que ce qu'on appelle le lobby du tabac
c'est trois choses c'est les cigarettes
sont les buralistes les buralistes sont
présentes dans tous les circonscriptions
ils connaissent le député ils peuvent
lui dire attention si tu prends si tu
votes une mesure contre le tabac on va
appeler nos adhérents à voter contre toi
ça fait peur à tous les députés ça et
puis vous avez la direction générale des
douanes qui représente l'État qui est
complice je le disais au moins de
l'entendre sur le sur les prix ça c'est
la première chose la deuxième chose
c'est que quand on essaye de contrôler
je disais que l'interdiction de la
publicité sur le sur le tabac était mal
était mal respecté avait été détournée
qui contrôle qui s'en occupe vous allez
voir la direction générale des douanes
elles s'en occupe pas elle vous dit mais
non mais ça c'est Bercy Bercy c'est le
fisc le fils du pas du tout c'est pas
nous c'est la concurrence la Direction
Générale de la Concurrence personne s'en
occupe donc il y a eu une complicité une
passivité et il a fallu que des gens
réussimone Veil Claude devint il y en a
eu d'autres mais si vous interrogez
Roselyne Bachelot qui a été ministre de
la Santé sous Nicolas Sarkozy qui était
plutôt
c'était plutôt une période probable
ou alors le ministre de la Santé
suivante il vous diront tous qu'ils ont
eu à faire à une bataille mais homérique
homérique contre une industrie qui au
fond en France et peu d'emploi c'est
beaucoup d'argent mais c'est assez peu
d'emploi pourquoi je le dis il y a une
complicité une passivité de pouvoir
publier et du monde politique ceci étant
il y a quand même une amélioration
concernant l'interdiction de la
publicité y compris à directe grâce
notamment aux associations à Droit des
non-fumeurs ou d'autres associations
c'était aussi un des volets d'ailleurs
qu'on avait permis dans la loi c'était
de permettre à des associations de
pouvoir engager des actions en justice
pour faire respecter la loi et de ce
point de vue en effet il y a quand même
eu une réduction alors il y a d'autres
une réduction de la publicité alors il y
a d'autres situations plus insidieuses
il y a des distributions de cigarettes
par exemple dans certaines
manifestations qui la sont complètement
interdites mais qui continue quand même
d'exister donc il y a en effet toujours
cette volonté de la part de cette
industrie de pouvoir effectivement
continuer à diffuser ces produits oui on
va l'extrait du documentaire parce que
c'est industrie du tabac a trouvé le
moyen de contourner cette interdiction
de publicité de la cigarette
quel que soit la forme qu'il va prendre
regardez dans leur discours les
dirigeants de l'industrie du tabac ont
participé la fin de la cigarette mais
presque tous ont choisis d'investir dans
la cigarette électronique sa publicité
est libre aux États-Unis
toutes les tactiques de vente désormais
interdites pour les paquets de tabac
sont à nouveau utilisés
le seul objectif de l'industrie c'est de
distribuer cette nicotine addictive et
de trouver un format pour la distribuer
une addiction c'est un comportement
compulsif on ne peut plus contrôler
c'est la substance chimique qui nous
contrôle et voilà la cigarette
électronique on peut en faire la
publicité ce n'est pas interdit en tout
cas aux États-Unis en tout cas pas au
moment où était réalisé cette cette
enquête alors les substituts à la
cigarette vous les avez cité tout à
l'heure la cigarette électronique on
vient d'en parler avec cet extrait et
puis on peut aussi citer le tabac
chauffé il y a d'autres substituts
possibles Philippe Auris se réjouit lui
d'inventer un monde sans fumée oui tout
à fait alors ça c'est formidable le
président de Philippe Maurice Joseph
holska se réjouit d'un monde sans fumée
évidemment et il réalise maintenant 39%
de son chiffre d'affaires grâce à ses
substituts avec un élément addictif s'il
en est si on a bien compris évidemment
ce film c'est la nicotine tout à fait
oui alors ce sont des petits bâtonnets
qui contiennent du tabac donc c'est du
tabac chauffé donc le tabac chauffé va
quand même donner des produits toxiques
donc alors le le message c'est vous
pouvez les utiliser parce que c'est sans
risque mais ce qu'on sait par des études
qui sont faites notamment aussi en
France
c'est que ce il y a de la production de
produits toxiques comme les
formaldéhydes acétaldéhydes aussi du
monoxyde de carbone c'est comme un
grille-pain en fait ça va chauffer et
produire des substances toxiques et
c'est vrai que c'est le c'est le produit
phare alors beaucoup vendu au Japon mais
quand même en France avec encore il y a
un modèle low cost qui s'appelle
l'île donc little
donc c'est vraiment extrêmement
promu par cette industrie qui trouve à
nouveau marché finalement j'ai vu par
ailleurs que le c'est assez récent ça
date de janvier dernier le Haut Conseil
de la santé publique des conseils
au tabacologue donc et au médecin de
conseiller de vapotage pour sevrer pour
se sevrer du tabac pardon je pense que
c'est ce que vous conseillez
déconseillez à vos patients
l'utilisation de cigarettes électronique
aujourd'hui comment dire la présentation
voilà c'est que les produits du vapotage
ne sont pas des médicaments comme des
médicaments qui ont subi des études qui
notamment ont fait des tirages au sort
et on vérifie bien que c'est efficace le
problème à l'heure actuelle c'est qu'on
a des études d'observation et on
s'aperçoit qu'en France on a 50% au
moins de vapo-fume dans des gens qui
fument et qui va potent et du coup le
message qu'il faut retenir du Haut
conseil c'est il faut arrêter de fumer
complètement si vous utilisez une
vapoteuse c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre
c'est pas parce que ça peut être en plus
d'un médicament d'aide à la raie mais il
faut c'est pas c'est très important
parce que c'est on réduit pas le risque
en étant vapo-fumeur pourquoi les
cigaritiers investissent massivement à
l'image de Philippe Maurice dans ces
produits de substitution ou au centre on
retrouve toujours ce fameux produit
addictif que la nicotine on l'a dit
c'est les scariétés anticipent en fait
la baisse ton ancienne dans les pays
occidentaux plutôt dans les pays riches
c'est pas le cas dans les pays en voie
de développement mais dans les pays
riches une baisse de la consommation de
cigarettes classiques
et donc on imagine que l'Angleterre la
France en 2050 il y aura quasiment plus
de fumeurs de de cigarettes classiques
mais donc ils ont inventé des substituts
des substitudes dans lequel on peut
mettre des saveurs particulières et pour
les vendre ils détournent l'interdiction
de la publicité en France il est
interdit de faire la publicité pour les
cigarettes pour le vapotage donc par
exemple on fait la publicité uniquement
pour l'emballage en disant et donc ils
ont été condamnés pour publicité
illégale on va faire que des vins de la
cité tout à l'heure on va faire dans des
soirées on va on va présenter le produit
il y a des jeunes on les soirées c'est
complètement illégal ça a continué à se
faire mais la stratégie est toujours la
même depuis le début on essaye de vendre
au public l'idée que il y a quelque
chose on peut fumer du tabac sans risque
pour la santé et ce qui est choquant
évidemment c'est que même si on n'a pas
d'études qui montrent clairement c'est
peut-être le cas mais qui montre
clairement que c'est dangereux pour la
santé en tous les cas il devrait
s'appuyer de le faire parce que c'est
interdit c'est interdit de vendre mineur
et c'est interdit de faire la publicité
qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils le vendent au
mineur ils font de la publicité c'est
exactement la même stratégie depuis des
années 60 on vivait tout à l'heure rien
n'a changé finalement dans la stratégie
marketing dans les cibles question alors
on peut plus naïf que des vins pourquoi
est-ce qu'on interdit pas la nicotine
qui semble l'élément addictif et sur
lequel repose tout de même encore la
stratégie des considéraités aujourd'hui
ça serait faisable d'interdire de
manière très très précise sur sur ce
point sur la question que vous me posez
ceci étant il y a quand même un certain
nombre de dispositifs d'interdiction
aujourd'hui qui comme cela vient d'être
indiqué malheureusement ne sont pas
respectés on est effectivement dans dans
la situation d'infraction permanente et
alors naturellement pour mettre fin à
ces infractions il y a qu'une solution
c'est d'aller devant un juge pour
permettre effectivement de sanctionner
ces infractions je vous disais tout à
l'heure il y a un certain nombre
d'associations qui le font et qui mène à
combat qui est tout à fait nécessaire
pour permettre effectivement le respect
de cette réglementation ceci étant ils
le font avec avec leurs moyens ils le
font avec
effectivement face à des à des à des
fraudeurs à qui naturellement se
débrouillent pour ne pas être pris comme
toute fraude comme toute mafia en
évoquait tout à l'heure le terme mafia
mais on est dans un rapport
effectivement face à de la délinquance
on est effectivement face à des
délinquants alors quand ils se font
prendre on arrive effectivement à les
faire condamner et puis on n'arrive pas
toujours à les faire prendre et bien on
va finir c'est la fin de cette émission
je suis désolé avec ces quelques
chiffres parce qu'on a beaucoup parlé de
l'Europe et c'est vrai qu'on fume moins
en Europe et vous venez nous le dire
peut-être va-t-on ne plus fumer du tout
d'ici quelques années cigarette
classique bien entendu
quelques chiffres mondiaux pour finir le
tabac tu jusqu'à la moitié de ce qui en
consomme aujourd'hui dans le monde le
tabac fait plus de 8 millions de morts
chaque année un peu partout dans le
monde 7 millions sont des vrais
consommateurs mais on oublie aussi tous
ceux qui sont victimes du évidemment
passif et puis enfin dernier chiffre
plus de 1% de 1,3 milliards de fumeurs
dans le monde vivent dans des pays à
revenus faible ou intermédiaire
autrement dit on parle de pays souvent
en cours de de développement et vous
nous le disiez tout à l'heure Marc le
mazuin finir sur ces chiffres là aussi
son insignisme assez important et c'est
de seisme de
l'industrie du tabac dont nous voulions
parler aujourd'hui dans cette émission
un grand merci vraiment à tous les trois
d'y avoir participé vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag de Badoc bien sûr sur
Twitter merci aussi à sel massali qui
m'a aidé à préparer comme à l'accoutumé
cette émission et puis moi je vous donne
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat loc
et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]